[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
breaking news
hunter biden's laptop
to release the location
of the secret service sex messages to
trump
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
they deleted those [ __ ]
they deleted the evidence of course they
deleted the evidence why would they want
the evidence out there in the open that
not only the president united states is
trying to overturn the government but
the secret service is trying to help him
it seems like full freakout mode over on
two central uh by grandpa poopypants
some people are pissed off that i keep
doing a screenshot of true social and
posting it on twitter they're like oh he
[ __ ] got kicked out twitter don't
give him a platform
block me then [ __ ] block me
block me stop complaining about my
account it's my [ __ ] i get to do with it
what the [ __ ] i want everybody else gets
to do with the [ __ ] what they want
this is important stuff i i know it
doesn't it sounds trivial
and it sounds ridiculous that you have
to look at how he's whining
but he's putting the stuff out into the
universe
and he's trying to do the same thing he
did
at the end of 2020 and 2021 and
continuing to do the soft coup
it's more of the same and you can't look
the [ __ ] away you can't just hide your
eyes while they try to steal away our
democracy what are you dumb
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize that this guy is trying to steal
away your democracy for his own power
for his own freedom from prison
because he's obviously freaked out about
thursday
he's very freaked the [ __ ] out about
thursday
now the reporting is is i believe that
the january 6 select committee received
one
just
one text message
[Laughter]
[Music]
from the secret service i hope to god we
get to see what that text message says
don't you
i want to see it i mean it's you know
really we laugh i'm laughing about this
and it's not really that funny that the
secret service
someone at the secret service has
deleted evidence
of the former president united states
committing sedition and treason
holy [ __ ] that's where we're at
that's where we're at and he is [ __ ]
terrified terrified about thursday
absolutely going bonkers
that's why i post his [ __ ] i don't post
his [ __ ] just to post his [ __ ] [ __ ]
from true social and [ __ ] fraudulent
social media
platform
i post it because it's very relevant
to our democracy folks
it's very relevant you cannot [ __ ]
hide your eyes away as he's trying to
gaslight his [ __ ] supporters
into [ __ ] violence that's what he's
trying to do
just like he did in december of 2020
when he was like yeah it's gonna be wild
oh yeah come to the capitol we're going
to march down there
we're going to hang mike pence i mean
did i say that out loud because i think
that's what we're going to find out
tomorrow too
tomorrow on thursday
during day eight of the january 6 select
public hearings we're going to find out
that trump was in the white house going
and let him hang him [ __ ] him
let him hang him he's just the vice
president what do i give a [ __ ] i'll get
a new one
that's what we're going gonna find out
and don't miss the coverage don't
[ __ ] miss this coverage this is gonna
be the banger baby
you thought we had a great hearing with
some of the with the seven before this
is gonna be the [ __ ] banger don't
miss it
don't miss our coverage either
you can go over to the midas touch
network youtube channel
just go over there and follow
and what you will be able to do is you
will be able to tune in an hour before
the hearing the hearing starts at eight
eastern eight pm eastern tomorrow
we're going to start our coverage at 7
00 p.m central we're gonna have a great
panel uh for you
with commentary an hour before during
the break because there will be a break
during the hearing and then
an hour or so after
and there may be a lot of news we may
have to take more than an hour to pick
it apart and unpack it all
i don't know exactly what's going to be
said no one does that's why you should
go watch
and listen and if you can't watch it
live you you should definitely subscribe
to the midas touch network youtube
channel
to watch it after the fact
and spread those clips around the
internet there's going to be plenty of
clips around the internet
of evidence of what donald trump didn't
do and more importantly what he did not
do
in that 180 so minutes as they laid
siege to the capitol and tried to kill
the vice president the house speaker and
other members of congress because they
didn't get their way
the american people voted in our
republic which is a democracy
and they didn't get their way it really
it really upset them
oh
they just couldn't live with it
so much so that they had to go ransack
our building and ransack our government
and try to overthrow it and make donald
trump the king [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
so tomorrow we're gonna find out what
the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants the mango mussolini
jesus was not doing
to stop the siege on the capitol to kill
the vice president and other other
prominent politicians in our government
to overturn it
with the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
attempt i think the other thing that
we're going to hear about
is the go-between
i think we're gonna hear a lot about the
go-between
between the oath keepers the proud boys
and the in the
former president the former guy i think
we're gonna find out who that is and
what that communication point was
i think we're gonna find that out i
think his name is gonna be stodger roon
or roger stone if you're counting
that's right i think steve bannon's
gonna come into the picture and play too
that's why steve bannon wanted it to
testify he changed his mind so did so
did trump they changed their mind no
executive privilege
all of a sudden they changed their mind
it has nothing to do with the contempt
charge in court he's in court right now
today and he's getting his ass handed to
him kyle chaney has a thread from uh a
live thread that he's tweeting from the
court courtroom
of steve bannon's trial i retweeted it
we'll go through some of it today on the
[ __ ] list roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the training
trends and boy do we have some
we got a lot of video to go through
today
um
to give you what's going on what to pay
attention to
and we we found out yesterday we we
covered the hoover dam video you've seen
there's explosion hoover dam it was
apparently a transformer that had
exploded um
so we won't be covering that but that
video was kind of scary i was like oh
what
explosion at hoover dam uh oh
we also have some more sesame place or
sesame street video to show you
um i know that seems insignificant but i
believe that this needs to be shown
and sesame street needs to make this
right
and whatever that may mean
people are going to criticize sesame
street for this
no matter what they do
um
you you probably watch the video of the
character in a parade
uh totally
ignore not only ignore but to wait tell
tell little black girls no i will not
engage with you
now during the parade and there's
another video out of the same type of
thing from the same character i'm not
sure if it's from the same day but
sesame street has released some
statements sesame place has released
some statements
so we'll get to the bottom of that as
well
i also want to show you the video of
alan dershowitz
alan dershowitz
complaining about losing his [ __ ]
library card i'm not [ __ ] you
i wouldn't [ __ ] you you're my favorite
well it's not he didn't lose his library
card but they won't let him come speak
at the library at martha's vineyard you
know what's [ __ ] funny about this
[ __ ]
they always [ __ ] complain and all
this [ __ ] and pointed democrats and
and and and and anti-trumpers that
they're the elites and they go to
martha's vin and here is no more
trumpian person than alan dershowitz he
claims to be a democrat i'm a democrat
you're a trumper you [ __ ] and the reason
why alan dershowitz is a trumper
is because trump has the goods on
dirtuits
has the goods on him we know he does
come on he's got the goods on everyone
else why wouldn't trump have the epstein
goods on dershowitz
why wouldn't he
of course he has the augustine mac
maxwell and then jeffrey epstein goods
on dershowitz
that's why dershowitz [ __ ] sycophants
for him
and dershowitz complaining that the
martha's venue library won't let him
come speak
but it's the leftist it's the leftists
and it's the anti-trumpers
who are the elitist
i don't know do you get to go speak at
martha's vineyards library i don't i
don't i don't
they wouldn't have my [ __ ] ass in
there for sure
for sure i don't even know that i'd want
to go in the martha's vineyard library i
might
just to go watch people spin on helen
dershowitz
[Laughter]
i might do that
now i own dershowitz complaining and the
best part is he's he's going and making
the media rounds he's on fox news he's
on newsmax oan wherever the [ __ ] these
trader tv networks are
with
tens of thousands of people of traitor
sycophants watching him
talk about how he's being silenced on tv
get the [ __ ] out of here
you dumb [ __ ] with your stupid
fake ass cancel culture
just because people in [ __ ] martha's
vineyard are like we don't want to hear
your dumb ass
at the library or anywhere else you
stupid bastard that doesn't mean that
you're being canceled it just means
you're a dumb [ __ ] you're just a stupid
[ __ ]
people don't want to listen to your dumb
ass they don't want to hear rudy
giuliani they don't want to hear
dershowitz they don't want to listen to
mike flynn they don't want to listen to
your [ __ ] stupid asses tucker carlson
any of these [ __ ] they don't
want to listen to you
you're a [ __ ] joke
no one gives a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
have to say
and we should continue to make these
people pariahs of society that's where
they belong crawl back underneath your
[ __ ] rock you chose this game [ __ ]
you chose this game to [ __ ] support
fascist
so now you live with it
my freedom is speech yeah you got the
freedom of speech but you don't have the
freedom from [ __ ] consequences and
being a pariah of society is a damn good
consequence if you're counting me into
it i think that's what we should do make
these [ __ ] pariahs make them
crawl back underneath the [ __ ] rocks
that they came out of [ __ ] them
so alan dershowitz should lose his
library card everywhere frankly i think
alan dershowitz should lose his [ __ ]
law license
fine by me [ __ ] them
let's do let's do that dershowitz
alan dershowitz
complaining that they won't let him
speak at a library
will they get him let him get naked with
a bunch of teenage girls at a swimming
pool i don't know
ask ask epstein go to the epstein case
and find out what trump's got on that
[ __ ] come on dershowitz we know
you we know we know it's not just trump
you scumbag the reason why people don't
want to listen to your stupid ass
allen [ __ ] dershowitz what else do we
have on on the plate today there's
plenty of stuff going on there's plenty
of of uh there's some new body cam
footage from the uvaldi
uh shooting that we're gonna watch today
uh it's not as disturbing as some of the
footage we watched
um last week
but this body cam footage
uh is from the officer whose wife was
shot on the in the classroom where they
wouldn't let him in he was in the
hallway they wouldn't let him in so they
wouldn't let him in to save his wife nor
would they go in to try to save his life
he just stood out there in the [ __ ]
hallway
stood out there
now we also have marjorie taylor green
walking around washington talking about
ukrainian flags on flagpoles because
the ukrainian first lady is in
washington
i don't understand how the [ __ ] she
doesn't know that we also have that dumb
dumb stupid [ __ ] her-footed idiot
talking about how aoc
was faking being arrested she said it
was a fake it was all fake she wasn't
actually arrested
oh jesus
it really is it really is uh getting
more and more um clear and the country
is
actually the polls are going in the
direction
that americans want members of congress
who were part of this seditious act on
january 6. if you remember a congress
they want your [ __ ] ass expelled at a
minimum
and the numbers are moving closer in
that direction now they need a
two-thirds vote to expel a member of
congress inside on the house floor
so you'd actually have to get
republicans to vote for something
i mean they they've even vote against
marriage equality why would they why
would they vote to expel seditious
members i mean they love the seditious
members those are some of their favorite
members of congress
speaking of members of congress and
seditious members of congress yet scott
perry at [ __ ]
ask asking
asking mayor pete now the secretary
i guess we can call him secretary pete i
i like mayor pete though that's a good
it's a good handle for him
now he does a marvelous job at dunking
these [ __ ] in the trash
um but mayor pete yesterday there's some
tape from
a committee hearing but scott perry
tries to tries to gaslight pete on how
much electric vehicles cost
and
pete
buddha judge the secretary of
transportation wads scott perry up and
dunks him in the [ __ ] trash
it's it's fantastic
and really honestly they're
pete buda judge is gonna be doing
government
well for a very long time
p buddha judge is not going anywhere as
far as government
and he's very good at it
i i believe he will remain as a
politician he will remain as a policy
maker in some shape or form whether it
be in an executive branch the federal
government a state government
or he will be a legislator
pete but a judge will be part of our
government hopefully
for a very long time because he's very
good at government he's very good at it
he's very good at policy he's a very
good politician and some people do not
like him because of some of the things
in the past or whatever
but he's very good at it that's he's a
serious policy maker
at the same time he's willing to throw
punches to win elections
that's very important when we're talking
about pro-democracy politicians and
pro-democracy part of
america because we only have one party
that's interested in democracy right now
and that's the democrats and that's just
the [ __ ] plain bear facts the other
side wants fascism it's not they're not
the same democrats and republicans are
not the same that's [ __ ] maybe at
one time they had more stuff in common
but they do not now republicans want a
fascist state
democrats want democracy
now pete but a judge is going to be
important part of that policy for a very
long time that pro-democracy coalition
that elects policy makers rather again
in an executive branch or in a
legislator that is going to be serious
about american policy and progressing
america's forward for the american
people for the voters us the people the
democracy
and he also again he's not he's he's
he's willing to go to the fight and win
elections so he will be with us for a
long time
and that
fact pisses the fascist off
way more way more
than that pete buddha judge is part of
the lgbtq community
pit that really [ __ ] pisses them off
it gets in their craw
that pete buddha judge is damn good at
[ __ ] government and not only is he
damn good at government he's damn good
at the politics part of government
really pisses them off so we're going to
watch a few of those videos uh today as
well
um there's some tucker carlson video but
there's but there's one video i want to
show you that a lot of people probably
um aren't paying attention to you
remember the the grandpa poopypants the
former guy the cheeto dust mobster
he was talking about the wisconsin
supreme court decision how oh and now
he's going to be the president because
the wisconsin supreme court ruled
wrongly in my opinion
that there that you can't have absentee
ballot drop boxes which is really
[ __ ] dumb
and we'll talk a little more about it
when we get to the [ __ ] list roundup in
this video
but the reason why it's [ __ ] stupid
is is if these these ballot boxes these
absentee drop boxes
they're very secure they're they're
they're watched
there's a lot of security around those
boxes the absentee drop boxes
to make sure that no one's [ __ ] with
those drop boxes
now when you take those drop boxes away
those secure drop boxes away and out of
the equation what people are gonna do
with their absentee ballot is they're
gonna stick it in a [ __ ] post office
box
they're gonna stick it in a [ __ ] box
that isn't as secure that's sitting on
the [ __ ] street corner what do you
it's it's such [ __ ] stupid-ass [ __ ]
that we have to [ __ ] that we have to
do this nonsense just so they get a
talking point
on their [ __ ] on their on their
traitor tv networks
that the supreme court in [ __ ]
wisconsin had to spend the time and the
state's money to do away with secure
drop boxes in exchange
for post office boxes that aren't as
secure
that's what's gonna happen an absentee
ballot can be mailed
that's why they're called mail-in
ballots [ __ ] boneheads and they're
going to stick it in a [ __ ] mailbox
that isn't as secure as the [ __ ]
absentee ballot drop boxes
so what you're what you're doing by
making this decision you [ __ ] idiots
is you're making the elections less
secure
because you're you are making the
ballots less secure by number one mixing
them in with other mail and number two
putting them in boxes that are less
secure than the actual drop boxes that
are meant for ballots
and really [ __ ] bone ended [ __ ]
these people are [ __ ] dumb they're
[ __ ] dumb and we need to call them
out now the video i'm gonna show you is
the actual uh assembly speaker
uh he's a republican in wisconsin
talking about how he got a [ __ ] phone
call from trump
a personal phone call this guy is not
stopping criming he's not trying to stop
the coup he's not trying to stop
overturning the election what we're
gonna see on thursday is what he did in
180 minutes
but i think we're going to get more
hearings in august and we're going to
see more tape of this [ __ ]
calling people trying to pressure them
to commit
election fraud and to try to overturn
elections now this this assembly speaker
was having none of it but you got to
remember he's running in wisconsin as a
republican so he has to dance around
this [ __ ]
but we'll watch that video this is super
important i mean this goes to the local
elections folks
you think you think that this select
hearing just has to do with the federal
government this is these [ __ ] these
[ __ ] traders are leaking down into
your state government where your [ __ ]
counties are operating where your
[ __ ] state legislators are operating
and they're trying to overturn the 20 we
are we are so close to the 22 election
and they are still trying to overturn
the 2020 election
they're
they are in coup mode
they are still trying to make donald
trump king because they know he's
[ __ ] finished if they don't
he knows he's finished if he doesn't
that's why i was posting his [ __ ]
statements
you [ __ ] snowflakes out there that
can't can't handle trump's statement
being posted on [ __ ] twitter get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
block me
mute it if you don't want to see it if
you want to hide your eyes from the
truth
and what he's doing
and how he's acting because the truth is
that he's acting like a scared [ __ ]
animal and i'm just trying to show you
what the [ __ ] he's trying to do
and how he's scared he's terrified
[ __ ] terrified about thursday
thursday's gonna destroy him folks
because everyone wants mayor garland to
to
to round him up handcuff him and
indict him convict him and put him in
prison
but after thursday the american people
are about to put him
in the in the court of public opinion
and they're going to convict him in the
court of public opinion and it's up to
you to spread the information that the
select committee gives us it's up to you
just like the ketchup and the secret
service that's why that's still in his
[ __ ] crawl the secret service thing
is still in his [ __ ] crawl and the
ketchup is still in his crawl the reason
why is because the american people
everyone was talking about it everybody
everybody was talking about how [ __ ]
much of a [ __ ] baby he is even joe
rogan on his podcast with his trumped up
[ __ ] audience is like yeah he's a
[ __ ] baby he's a man baby even joe
rogan has has has the latitude to call
trump a man baby and make fun of him for
being such a [ __ ]
an adderall
a souped-up adderall baby
a grown adult
saying not fair not fair in his [ __ ]
statement
all caps not fair like a [ __ ]
four-year-old
and yes it is relevant it's relevant to
the time it's relevant to the news so
i'm gonna post it you don't like it [ __ ]
you
get off my feed
but the american people need to see how
he's reacting
because it's going in the right
direction here
i don't know that people are waking up
but they're coming to terms with what
they know is true his supporters have
always known he's such a piece of [ __ ]
they've always known that
they did that [ __ ] back in 2016 when
they're like well i didn't really vote
for trump i like mike pence
the same people are now gonna have to
answer on thursday if they voted for
trump because they like mike pence
because he's a great christian you know
he's a [ __ ] bigot is what they mean
he's a bigot he hates gay people and he
hates brown people that's what i like
about mike pence
that [ __ ]
but they're gonna find out that the
president united states trump at the
time during the coup
was gonna what people [ __ ] murder him
to make sure he stayed in power oh well
good vote
good vote in 2016 if you voted
for donald trump because mike pence the
great christian was his [ __ ] vice
president get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] the american people are gonna
know donald trump knows they're gonna
know that's why he's freaking the [ __ ]
out about tomorrow
he's freaking out about tomorrow's prime
time hearing because it's in prime time
and they're gonna indict the [ __ ] out of
him in public in the public court of
opinion
and he's gonna be convicted in the
public court of opinion
it's gonna happen and really honestly
as far as his
attempted run
in 2024 to try to stave off criminal
indictments it's not going to work
anyways
for the criminal indictments
or the court of public opinion he's
already going to be [ __ ] destroyed
he won't beat a ron desantis he won't do
it he will not beat a ron desantis in a
[ __ ] primary won't happen
today not
not let alone a year or two from now
but who gives a [ __ ] about that race we
got a race right here in front of us
2022
and by god if he decides to run to stave
off criminal indictments that's going to
help the democrats
that puts trump on every [ __ ]
ballot out there
every [ __ ] ballot it puts him on
there
and that's the way you should politicize
it to your friends your family your
community members your fellow church
parishioners
if he decides to run to stave off
criminal indictment which the doj
released a statement after rachel maddow
uh released the the memo from merrick
garland and don winslow went on a
[ __ ] freak out rampage on twitter got
everybody freaked out about a memo that
doesn't mean [ __ ]
the doj has said no we don't give a [ __ ]
if he runs for president or not it's not
going to stop us from investigating him
if there's crimes on january 6.
so i guess that one [ __ ] the bid i was
right
again imagine
but it's good if donald trump decides to
run
that's great i'm excited if he i i wish
he would announced it a month ago
and the only reason why he would run is
because he sees indictments coming which
is even better for us
so lean into it politicize it that's
what we have to do
we have to win this election we have to
do the politics to do the governing if
you want to have a pro-democracy
government now is the time to politicize
the [ __ ] out of everything
everything all of it
every single bit of it
so stay pissed have strategic outrage
and don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble
maggot edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists the first
lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon i was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the word that i'm
struggling with i chose babble mag
edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now i can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us as you do every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch
cybercast live to the midas touch
facebook page
you gotta come join us tomorrow you
really do
have to come join us tomorrow we're
going to be airing at our normal time
right here on the tony michaels podcast
so make sure to hit that like and
subscribe and whatever the hell you're
supposed to do on youtube subscribe to
the minus our to the tony michaels
podcast but also go over to the minus
touch page because tomorrow night in
prime time now we will start an hour
early from the gavel so the gavel is
supposed to go down on the hearing at
eight eastern but come early come early
an hour at 7 00 pm eastern we will have
commentary from the midas touch network
and all of our great commentary from our
great panel and they will be there to
join us uh the likes of texas paul the
mizellas brothers i'm sure michael cohen
will come in maybe we'll get lee mcgowan
politics girl again
we're gonna have some good texas paul
the midas mighty favorite
i'm even gonna try to get jordy to
showed up i i don't know if he ju and if
jordy can hear me out there jordy you
gotta come on this time maybe we get
your microphone
to work
everyone loves jordy jordy's like the
favorite over at the with the mizellas
brothers on the midas touch podcast but
we're also we'll also probably have the
legal af staff
not just ben but also popock and kfa
karen and dippolo i'm sure we'll have
them as well
to talk to us and i think we have a few
special guests
um that that will join us i'm hoping
we're working on some special guest some
special commentary
maybe right after or right before during
the break so come join us tomorrow on
the midas touch network
for day eight
the prime time hearing where you're
gonna hear the tick tock of what the
cheeto dust mobster didn't do to stop
his vice president from being killed
by the mob the violent insurrectionist
so that he could become king
come find out tomorrow thursday on the
midas touch network again go to the
minus touch network
youtube channel
and watch their watch live come to the
chat
there's going to be a chat so there'll
be thousands and thousands of people oh
my gosh i think
we've had almost 20 000 people watching
all at once
at some point
and we've had over i think we're gonna
have over two million views
of the of the hearings just on the midas
touch network
holy [ __ ]
two million views so come be part of the
action
tomorrow evening during prime time
during the hearing
as the court of public opinion indicts
the former the former guy
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy
pants
donald trump himself
come join us tomorrow again 7 eastern
on the midas touch network youtube
channel so go over and subscribe there
we got a lot of news to get to and that
gabe hasn't joined us yet because i
think he's still
busy editing his what was that what was
that what was that he's going to be
releasing what was that um today i think
he's releasing maybe one or two today i
don't know he's got a couple that he's
working on so i think he's still he's
still busy doing some editing so gabe
may join us at the top of the hour if he
completes and hopefully he'll have it
done where we can actually we can play
the what was that here
on today's episode but let's get to the
[ __ ] list roundup start the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we've reached the part
of the
show where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends of the day
we go through the news
on the [ __ ] list roundup
the [ __ ] last roundup i got a lot of
video to show you so let's get right
into it let's not waste a lot of time
here going to the [ __ ] list
one of the uh first things i want to
show is the
new body cam footage um
that's going around
of the officer whose wife was shot she
was a she was a teacher she was inside
the classroom and i believe it is this
officer right here this gentleman right
here
you will see one body cam where he comes
up and he says that she's in the
classroom and then you will see where
he's trying to get in the classroom and
they took him away
let's watch
he said it's his wife's classroom
um
let's continue here
there's going to be another angle here
here's the other angle
and i'm i'm guessing they're standing
outside
the one of the doors because uh
if you remember correctly
in the the rob elementary school some of
the classrooms are connected by a
bathroom
so
when you enter one classroom you're able
to enter the other classroom through a
connected bathroom i'm not sure which
door they're standing out here but i'm
assuming it's one of the doors and
you'll watch the officer that we just
where he said his wife was in the
classroom
you'll see you'll see that um
he walks tries to walk past these
officers and they won't let him in the
room let's watch
reuben
she said she shot john is what he says
um
he apparently um
she was texting him or calling him
and telling
her her husband who is the police
officer here they was shot now this guy
has has
some nerve to go
to go save his wife
um but they won't allow him they don't
want to go in that room
i don't know why they chose not to go in
that [ __ ] room i still cannot figure
this out even knowing knowing that there
were people still alive with that
[ __ ] murderous piece of [ __ ] that
greg abbott
wrought on this elementary school that's
right greg abbott did this
if greg abbott would not assign that law
that [ __ ] would not have been
able to receive those [ __ ] weapons
matter of fact greg abbott in his
dereliction a duty to protect texans by
passing laws to make sure these people
don't get these kind of [ __ ] weapons
as easily as this is this is this child
did he was 18 years old
he's a child
he's in derelict of duty and he caused
this
but these officers will not allow
officer rubin here and you'll see
they'll walk him away
and make sure to walk him away
from saving his wife's life
where she's still alive but bleeding out
what a sad situation in uvalde what a
sad situation in uvalde jesus [ __ ]
christ
i can't even imagine how [ __ ] pissed
off that community is at this point i
mean i'm [ __ ] infuriated about it i
know you're infuriated about it
i can't even [ __ ] imagine living in
that community
and i watched a live uh
feed of one of the city council meetings
the other day and people are [ __ ]
pissed
about what happened in that city
and what happened in that elementary
school
and what happened in that state and they
[ __ ] should be
now there's more video of a press
conference of some of the protesters
that were marching with beto o'rourke
um maybe we'll pull that up here in here
in a bit
um where
beto just went down and said how can i
help whatever i can do
and they were like march with us so he
marched with them he's like whatever i
can do to help i'll help you
like a real [ __ ] governor would
instead greg abbott not only allowed
that [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] to get that weapon of war
to murder and and tear apart those
little babies and those two teachers
but then he lied about it he [ __ ]
lied not to just you valdi but to the
state of texas and the american people
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
talking about making these [ __ ]
pariah
you take away dershowitz's library card
let's take away
greg abbott's governorship [ __ ] them
speaking of alan dershowitz in his
library card here's um
here's a here's oh here's a little
epstein's friend
uh jeffrey epstein's
massage buddy talking to um
gretchen greta van susteren
on traitor tv greta you really fallen by
the wayside here
you know you used to be on fox news and
you went to msnbc you claim to be
[ __ ] non-biased [ __ ] what are you
doing on a traitor tv news network
come on give me a break greta you're a
[ __ ] traitor and here you are
interviewing one of epstein's massage
buddies you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
letting him complain about how he's
being canceled on your trader tv network
blasting it broadcasting it live
the [ __ ] out of here with this nonsense
listen to this piece of [ __ ]
this this oversized thumb complain
about how he's being [ __ ] canceled
yeah
you're not being canceled people just
don't want to hear your nonsense i wrote
my book on the prize principle you're
right i have been punished severely i
can't no you haven't been punished
severely you should be punished way more
severely for the crimes that you've
committed dershowitz the crimes that
trump is holding over your head to be
his little sycophant
and his little his little
legal microphone you piece of [ __ ]
speak at the library in martha's
vineyard i can't speak in the synagogue
in martha's vineyard you shouldn't be
able to speak anywhere frankly
the newsmax should even be embarrassed
to have your dumbass on their [ __ ] on
their broadcast
what are you talking about
you're lucky that you can even get on
these trader tv news networks you piece
of garbage
i can't speak in uh the community center
uh i have been silenced because you're a
danger to all the children and
especially the young girls
you're a danger to them you're a
predator you [ __ ] idiot no matter
what you say we know you're a [ __ ]
predator
we know we know that's why justine
maxwell and jeffrey epstein hung himself
and she won't talk
that's what that's what your massage
buddy donald trump who is jeffrey
epstein's little little massage buddy
too
jeffrey epstein delivering girls
straight directly to mar-a-lago for
donald trump
come on by people who don't want to hear
my perspective because i defended the
constitution on behalf of president
trump because he held he held he held
the sexual crimes that you've had over
your head yeah we get it we know why we
don't want to hear from you we
understand why alan dershowitz we don't
want to [ __ ] hear from you you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
now this guy this [ __ ] guy
um here's some news from kyle
and cheney just in from the new york
supreme court justice has ruled rudy
giuliani speaking of another big piece
of [ __ ]
now rudy giuliani to appear
for testimony before the fulton county
grand jury on august 9th per a filing by
the d.a fannie willis this morning so
rudy giuliani is now going to be forced
to appear for a deposition and testimony
before the grand jury down in georgia
that fanny willis the d.a in fulton
county has convened
for the purpose of getting to the bottom
of the election fraud
that the former guy and his [ __ ] and
his legal team
quote unquote
we're trying to feed
to wrath this burger and the other
election fish officials in georgia
here's the thing again i go back to
grandpa poopypants donald trump is
[ __ ] freaking out on true social this
morning
freaking the [ __ ] out and i know a lot
of you don't want to go get an account
on true social i understand that i i
really didn't want an account myself
necessarily but i wanted to be able to
go over and look and see what the [ __ ]
he was doing and how he was freaking the
[ __ ] out
and he is freaking out about this this
morning freaking out that rudy giuliani
is going to have to that the
new york supreme court
justice is going to force him to testify
in front of the grand jury
freaking the [ __ ] out my phone call was
perfect oh it was a perfect fat where
have you heard this [ __ ] before it was a
perfect phone call
with this with georgia officials
trying making sure that i was trying to
overturn the election the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
kyle has some more breaking news for us
this morning
um
see if i can find it on the steve bannon
trial
and here is the feed that i put up if
you're wanting to see it uh he was live
tweeting the bannon's trial so i
actually retweeted his feed i'll retweet
it now but
kyle goes into
uh what is happening bannon trial has
resumed with doj arguing that bannon is
improperly injecting politics into the
jury's minds doj wants the limited uh to
limit the questions his lawyers can ask
on that and judge nichol agrees so judge
nichols
in this in the presiding magistrate over
this trial
has told bannon's team that they can't
inject politics
really it really hurts their case when
they can't inject politics because
that's the only [ __ ] play they have
here is to whine and complain about the
politics of it and the judge has no
[ __ ]
[ __ ] to give
in this case you don't get that skate on
crime because the crime you committed
was on one side of the aisle get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] it's a
legal subpoena
from a legally convened bipartisan panel
select committee of congress
um
it goes on about the trial and i haven't
read some of the updates uh but let's
see
see if we can
it looks like they're still it within an
in within the last hour
they were still um going back and forth
in the trial i thought this one was
significant though in this thread uh
prosecutors now asking amerling about
why it wanted records and emerling is
one of the i believe she's a staffer
um yeah she's chief counsel
so she is one of the lawyers
from the select committee and she was
one of the ones that worked on the
subpoena for steve bannon
emeralding about why it wanted records
related to bannon's quote war room i
call it the trader tv news network here
podcast
she's recalling his
all hell is breaking loose tomorrow
comments on on january 5th all the while
br bannon cracks a subtle smile as they
discuss his show that's what all this is
about
that's what they're scared of that's
what they're pissed off about
steve bannon's gonna go to prison
because they're gonna lock him up and he
ain't gonna be able to [ __ ] do his
traitor tv podcast that's what they're
[ __ ] pissed off about that's what
they're terrified of that they won't be
able to stoke people into violence
during the election that's what they're
trying to do
that's their goal here is to is for
people to commit non-sanctioned violence
in the name of trump in the name of
trumpism and trump candidates getting
their [ __ ]
asses handed to him
because right now the trump candidates
are getting their asses handed to him
herschel walker dr oz jd vance and some
of these [ __ ] senate races are
absolutely getting [ __ ] crushed
in the polls because they suck and it
sucks to suck
and trump can't pick these [ __ ]
boneheads
and they have to get on they have to put
their cheeto dust knee pads on
and worship at the altar of trump
and it and yes it is affecting him in
these states
so yeah
[ __ ] bannon [ __ ] his trader tv news
network podcast
[ __ ] him
i hope they give him the full two years
which i would imagine that the judge is
probably going to get banned in 14 to 18
months
when this is all said and done when they
convict him he'll probably get 14 to 18
months would be my guess
the prosecutors are gonna ask for the
full two years i'm sure
just because of his past
because he's been federally indicted
before even though he had a pardon he's
been federally indicted before
and he has a history of violence and
crime
this [ __ ]
and he's a danger to our society
so but that's my prediction 14 18 months
is what you're going to see steve bannon
get for his contempt charge just his
contempt charge and that's important
but i'll digress on that so let's and
and thank you kyle for keeping us
updated inside the bannon trial
his contempt trial so we know what that
that criminal [ __ ] is up to so go follow
that thread now i'm sure kyle will be
giving more updates um as there's
updates in that trial
um
i want to get to
um
this
let's see i want to wait on that video i
i want to i want to see if we can go to
gabe on that video let's go to this
video here speaking of traitors
and and election fraud and trump trying
to trying to commit a soft coup this is
the video i was talking about earlier
where the supreme court in wisconsin
ruled that absentee ballot boxes are
unconstitutional which is really [ __ ]
stupid again
the idea that they're going to get rid
of secure ballot boxes to make sure
people have a secure place to drop their
ballot
all you're going to do is now make them
drop them in unsecure boxes
they don't have cameras they don't have
sensors on them
it's mixed in with other mail the ballot
is so it has to be sorted
it actually has to go through the mail
system
instead of directly and directly to the
election office
there's not there's not a secure
procedure
to take the balance out of the boxes to
collect the ballots it's just simply the
mail
this is really [ __ ] stupid
really [ __ ] dumb
that the the idea is that we're gonna
get rid of secure ballots that people
want to drop their ballot to make sure
their ballot is [ __ ] submitted and
counted
when they get an absentee ballot that
they're gonna stick it and right here in
the video you [ __ ] see a goddamn
mailbox
right behind these [ __ ]
you see the reporter standing here
asking the the assembly speaker who is a
republican and right behind him is a
goddamn mailbox
now let me ask you how secure do you
think this mailbox is when someone
throws a ballot in there and puts up
their red flag how secure
especially when the truck comes by grabs
the mail puts it in a bag and then goes
back to this facility and back to that
facility and then eventually works its
way to the election office how secure do
you think that is
look the reason why republicans don't
want secure ballot boxes
that's part of the feature
they they want to make sure ballots get
lost in the mail especially
in a high turnout election
they don't want ballots they don't want
every ballot to be counted in a high
turnout election they'll [ __ ] lose
so that's a feature not a benefit that
they're making the elections less secure
and the other reason why they want to do
this is so they can blame like look
look see it's less secure yeah because
you made it less secure
there should be secure ballot boxes all
over this country all over this
[ __ ]
we should have secure ballot boxes
that only ballots enter there's a
procedure for those ballots to be
removed and counted from that box that
box
has certain sensors or cameras or
something on it to make it even more
secure we have that technology yes it's
expensive but our elections are
important
so so this is really [ __ ] dumb but
listen
listen to the the house speaker here let
me show you what his his name is because
i forget it's robin vos
matt smith is a reporter here uh for a
uh uh
for wisn 12 news in milwaukee
but he's talking to the assembly speaker
robin vos here
and robin vos says someone called him
hmm
listen to this
when's the last time you talked to the
former president president trump uh
within last week
what what
he talked to him within the last week
this this is not this is not from 2020
folks
this is from this week he talked to this
[ __ ] last week so after the
wisconsin supreme court decision
donald trump is on the phone
on the phone
with the assembly speaker of wisconsin a
republican who's running for re-election
by the way watch in the last week yeah
before after he tweeted about that
before and what was that conversation
like that's you know it's one of those
that it's very consistent he makes his
case which i respect um he would like us
to do something different he makes his
case
he makes his case of why i should
overturn the election so that he'll
support me because you noticed he he he
talked about trump's statement and again
folks this is why trump's statements are
still relevant now some of them are not
some of them are just plain [ __ ]
garbage
just plain [ __ ] garbage it's not even
worth looking at
but some of his statements are
absolutely relevant because he's
projecting he's projecting his crimes
through his public statements because he
called this guy a rhino and the reason
why this guy is a rhino is because he
wouldn't [ __ ] crown trump king in
wisconsin the same way he wanted his
[ __ ] mob to hang mike pence he
doesn't like this guy because he called
and he threatened him i mean made
suggestions i mean
get out of here the guy [ __ ] called
you robin boss
and i think the select committee should
subpoena robin boss
absolutely she's subpoena robin boss
it has to do with january 6 and 2020
election and trying to overturn it let's
subpoena this [ __ ] and see what
trump told him i wonder i wonder if
robin boss recorded that phone call for
in wisconsin i explained that it's not
allowed under the constitution he has a
different opinion and he put the tweet
out so he has a different opinion i
explained to him i explained to him that
i can't overturn an election that even
if you pressure me to do crimes it would
be a crime it would be illegal to do
what you're saying
he's still doing it folks
he's still doing it and he's gonna keep
doing it
right this guy's gonna keep committing
crime now this is not everyone's like oh
well then you should lock him up
look
actually frankly we should let this guy
keep [ __ ]
committing crimes
to hypothetically hang himself with
[ __ ] federal election crimes this guy
is not stopped from january 6.
the crimes that were committed on
january 6 where he was trying to
overthrow our election and obstruct an
official proceeding he is still doing
those crimes
right now
and he's tampering with witnesses he's
trying to get he's trying to get state
officials to commit
election fraud
for him
so that he can be crowned king
and they won't do it
very important stuff so when you tell me
trump's statements are irrelevant you're
[ __ ] full of [ __ ]
you are full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they're irrelevant
he's projecting his crimes is what he's
doing and that's most important to see
he's also
he's also asking he's begging him for
money this is another relevant one
this is an email josh marshall uh
tweeted this out
uh josh has here he he tweets fifty
dollars to unlock secret video i said
who in the actual [ __ ] would
i'm not [ __ ] this is a goddamn email
from the save america pack
that's the other thing about this is if
he runs for president he has to give up
this pack you know that right
he's got to give up the pack he's got to
walk away from the pack to run his
presidential camp his 2024 presidential
campaign anyways it says friend did you
see donald trump's email earlier
he released a secret video that he
recorded is this like is this like a p
tape
that's what i want to know is this a p
tape
the link says follow this link to donate
fifty dollars to unlock trump's secret
video message are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me we gotta get gabe sanchez
to get on it and figure out what this
[ __ ] video message is don't you think
we need to have gabe sanchez make sure
we track down this goddamn video
that's the other thing everyone's
pointing out in the uh in the chat here
the email the email heading is this
this will self-delete soon
nothing projecting more than this
[ __ ] on the week that the secret
service text messages are deleting he's
projecting that his own emails are going
to delete soon make sure to delete your
emails in your text seditionist you
[ __ ] traitors jesus [ __ ] christ
jesus christ these people he just can't
stop he can't stop criming he can't stop
the griff he can't stop projecting that
he's a [ __ ] criminal he can't stop
and trust me this is not good for him
this is nin kapoop type [ __ ]
this is really really bad for him
and i don't know if maybe it's maybe
it's like a pornhub or only fans video i
don't know but i would imagine it i i
think it's probably the p tape
would be what i would assume
that this is
uh citizens
uh for ethics
they had tweeted out yesterday uh
citizens4ethics.org
it looks like they'll be actually
sending a complaint which will probably
be followed by a lawsuit and look they
say looks like the secret service broke
the law we can't just sit back and hang
tight
so we sent a complaint to the doj so um
citizens for ethics here is trying to
make sure
that this as much as we're joking about
the
uh deletion of sex messages between the
secret service and trump or about trump
and then the secret maybe that's the
secret video maybe that's the secret
video they deleted
the video that they sent on these text
messages i don't know who who could tell
who could tell but apparently
hugo says here in the guardian he says
new us secret service turned over just
one text message
to the january 6 committee
in response
to a subpoena compelling production of
communications from the day before
and the day of the capital attack the
insurrection the cheeto dust kangaroo
coupe
so alls they received on tuesday because
remember the committee wanted those by
tuesday they said that's the deadline
you gotta have them by tuesday and i
believe it's because they're they wanted
to
see what it was to see if they should
feature it on thursday in the timeline
well they got one text message and i
think they only got one text message
just to say well we gave you a text
message
you gave us a deadline and we gave you a
text message what do you think it says
who this new phone who dis i don't know
who knows
who knows what the text message says
maybe that's the secret video like i
said
that one text message is just the secret
video that is being hidden by the trump
email
jesus christ
well
let's go to
oh here's a good one let's go to some
marjorie taylor green video
let's see what this trader's up to
she's talking to a cat turd i'm not
[ __ ] you
i wouldn't you're my favorite turd look
at this [ __ ] look at this speaking of
cat [ __ ]
she's on in the litterbox.com i'm not
kidding you this is [ __ ] real in the
litterbox.com she's on cat turds podcast
or whatever the [ __ ] it is now she's
sitting in her studio
not talking into her microphone the
appropriate way again
we're not going to listen to a lot of
this and there's not a lot of it but
let's let's hear what she and let's see
what her and cat turd are having a
really deep conversation about
prince is i believe in accountability
and i believe in not just saying
something but following through on it
and i believe that republicans need to
prove to the american people that we are
the party of american nationalism
and christian nationalism i'm a
christian i have we are not christian
nationalists in this country that's
called nazis you [ __ ] ninka poop
we do not want your christian
nationalism
and we're and we're sick and tired of
hearing you're proud of being a fascist
and a nazi or sick of it
but listen this is important she's going
on a [ __ ] goddamn talk show called in
the litterbox.com to join cat turd
to brag to the deep dark web
she's injecting herself here with the
stephen stephen bannon
army
because he's about to go to prison
that's why i think she's starting this
show
is to really take the torch
for nazi propaganda when steve bannon
gets locked up because of contempt
i think that's the plan here
listen to this nonsense about this
christian nationalism how she's proud to
be a nazi no problem saying i'm a
christian nationalist and i think that's
an identity that we need to embrace
because those are the policies that
serve every single american regardless
of how they vote they can you are so
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you
talking about you [ __ ] want to
go back 200 years
you want a fascist state
where where at the lgbt community is
ostracized
and cast out from society because of who
they are and who they love
get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ]
could be a democrat and a progressive
but christian nationalist or american
nationalist america first policies
nazis
[ __ ]
nazis
she keeps saying america first policies
this is all nick fuentes [ __ ]
this is what this is this is an attempt
to court the deep dark web these [ __ ]
trolls out there
to stoke
stochastics terrorism just like dakota
adams said about the highland park
shooter
that's what is going on here that's what
steve bannon's tapped into that's what
they love about him
they're trying to stoke violence because
they know 2020 is not gonna go their way
they're very they're very they're very
[ __ ] terrified
that 2022 is not going to go their way
and they want to make sure that there's
just as much or more violence than what
happened on 2020 when it doesn't go
their way and that's why they're talking
about christian nationalism and america
first and manga and all this [ __ ]
because they want terrorism they want
people to commit terrorism you know like
dress up in a hoodie
and and plant bombs around washington dc
during the certification of results
marjorie taylor green you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] still
serve those people because they're the
right policies for everyone friends no
no fascism does not serve everyone
that's the point that's what you want
you don't want it to serve everyone
yeah
and everyone's hey
you can't pay attention to her they're
telling you what they want to do folks
they're telling you they're saying it
out loud what they want to do
why do you want to close your ears and
not listen to them telling you exactly
their plan
stop stop [ __ ] ignoring what they're
saying
realize what they're saying realize the
danger that is in front of you and do
something about it
engage in the ballot
we have to have you pro-democracy people
out there
engaging in our democracy to save it
that's what it's going to take
this isn't going to fix itself this
isn't going to work itself out
eventually
it won't look at this bonehead here's
another video she posted this video
she's in washington walking around on
the street
at night or in the early morning maybe
she's i don't know walking around with a
hoodie carrying bags of dynamite around
i don't know what she likes to do and
walk when she's walking around in the
dark
washington i couldn't tell you there's
probably video evan somewhere of it but
here she is with her cell phone creating
a
social media influencer video about how
the ukrainian flag is flying in
washington
now i don't know she knows this but
our ukrainian delegation is in
washington
with the first lady of ukraine that's
why the flag
is out because they're there as a
special delegation
to visit our government which i don't
know is located in um washington dc you
stupid [ __ ] trunt
listen to this nonsense
dc
ukraine washington dc
what do we have right here
[Music]
oh look
washington dc and ukraine
so they can't they can't make again they
can't make [ __ ] videos anymore about
the how high gas prices are i haven't
seen those videos in a while oh gas
prices so high because they've been
[ __ ] plummeting
because our government did what they
could do to affect the price of crude
to up the supply the world supply not
just our nation's supply because
around the world they're still having
trouble with supply we're trying to
reduce prices all around the world
to reduce the economic
woes that the
war in ukraine which russia has waged
against the sovereign state that
murderous dictator putin
who um he needs to be eating up his ammo
sandwich here soon hopefully he'll
devour that ammo sandwich soon
but they're trying to
have the effect of making sure that
crude is going down and it has
and you notice that the republicans
can't [ __ ] stop with this nonsense
about flags in washington dc hanging on
poles because the ukrainian delegation
is in washington
which is a very standard thing when a
another country's delegation makes an
official trip to washington this is
really [ __ ] bone-headed [ __ ] but
these people believe this garbage they
believe it
they believe this garbage and i think
gabe sanchez knows all too well about
the garbage they believe yeah it's just
a [ __ ] pile of garbage like like
literally she's walking around going
she's walking around in her hoodie with
her with her bomb whether i mean her bag
right and she's she's like oh look at
the ukrainian flag
like i and again maybe she does or maybe
she doesn't realize that there's an
official ukrainian delegation in
washington right visit there on an
official meeting but that's why the
[ __ ] flag is out there because
they're there it really is [ __ ]
bone-in type [ __ ] man it's just she's
gonna you know it's a false flag it's a
ukrainian flag it's like i went out this
morning to go plant some bombs and all
of a sudden ukrainian flags waving
everywhere really ruin my morning
planting bombs around washington dc i
don't know i'm just allegedly allegedly
a legend
same stride very similar sneakers
right right
you sent me a link here what's this link
yeah yeah no that's uh that is
the reason for people out there
listening watching the reason it took me
a while to get on the show today is
because yeah why are why are you late
i already let him know i let him know
that you were working
but that's the link for it because i was
trying to help i was like oh screw it
i'll just put it straight onto youtube
uh so you could just play it from your
oh okay so so i've got a link a special
link here to show the special link
special so we're going to see the the
what was that but before i go there
because you know this is we haven't
watched marjory the green or in these
dumb [ __ ] do gas price videos here
lately no they haven't you know this is
this is the ukrainian flag thing this is
this whole stupid thing they do where
they make some kind of social media
video that has nothing to do with the
truth it's not coupled with reality
right but they haven't been able to do
these games
because it's like the last 31 32 days or
something has gone straight decline
and then they because if they were if
they admit that the i mean the only the
only admission of the price going down
was on day 27 and day 27 was on fox news
like whoa whoa whoa guys you're dropping
the prize way too quickly right oh my
gosh mom and pop shops and it's like oh
my god since when have you cared about
mom and pop shops but also the fact that
you're trying to find the negative spin
on the prices going down that all the
last few months you've been bitching
it's their personality trait it's their
only personality trait at this point
like you a troll a tr you post something
i don't know about roe v wade being
overturned and like what about gas
prices like it's their only personality
trade at this point and and the
administration and really it's it's the
world in an effort to try to increase
the supply to drop the price of fuel
because it's hurting not just our county
but economies around the world right
right like this affects us and it's
because inflation across you know right
you know the euro has an effect
everywhere the dollar you know there are
all these things that are having global
impacts right and it's not just the us
but again according to
uh republicans
biden is the one who has all of the
switches and controls
you know these things that's not a bad
idea that we should give him the
switches and controls on gas prices
because he's he's done an obvious it
went up it's going back down but here's
the other thing
do you remember there was a guy in 2016.
i don't know if you remember this guy
really shitty haircut stupid [ __ ]
suits really long ties yeah yeah real
annoying
making fun of making fun of people just
all kinds of nonsense this guy ran for
president and he said what he would do
is build a wall and mexico would pay for
that wall for pay mexico would pay for
our border security right right after he
was like i'll do that right after he
said
mexicans were
drug dealers rapists right murderers
right
perfect perfect [ __ ] dip diplomatic
uh policy yeah right out of the game
again came down here and was like i'm
running for president [ __ ] brown people
and we're gonna make them pay for a wall
is great that's what he's like we're
going to make it great again why are you
going to make it great again for the
white people but even the white people
are suffering under you but
even he would even hold rallies and they
would chant build the wall and then he
would say who's going to pay for it and
the entire all all dozen of them would
say
mexico
right what's funny about that what's
funny about that
is mexico did not pay for the wall that
he tried to build did not pay for it
they [ __ ] told him to [ __ ] off you
know what biden actually did this last
week
biden actually got the mexican
government to commit with with real
diplomacy because he's a real leader got
him got mexico to commit to helping
secure the border between mexico and the
united states right actually mexican
government paying for security at the
border to secure that board
joe biden secured that money
it's amazing what will happen when you
get someone who's actually serious about
fixing a problem instead of just saying
build a wall it's going to be wonderful
it's going to have
barbed wire on it it's going to be
golden and it'll say trump it's amazing
yeah it's amazing when you have a
president who is competent right i don't
have to do this right they say well
sleeping joe budden he's just phoning it
in from the basement you know it's like
if if that was true
he is the laziest most efficient
president i've ever seen
the roi there the roi on his time like
if sleepy joe biden is sleeping 16 hours
a day and he's and he's only doing
president stuff like two that is a huge
roi
i wish i could just like work two hours
in front of a camera and then do nothing
else all day and that would be amazing
that would be crazy
but it's crazy what happens when you
have someone who actually has experience
leadership and willing to put in the
hard work and also the most important
part is willing to come to the table
and be collaborative with another party
as opposed to
you guys don't want to do it and i'm not
gonna do it hey guys how do we nuke a
hurricane like the [ __ ] dumbass like
this was anyone new mexico city too at
one point yeah he was like we'll knew
he's like we'll shoot we'll shoot uh
missiles missiles into mexico and then
we won't say it's us
as if they won't know right they're like
where did it come from it came from the
north right it was canada well it wasn't
canada though we don't have that long
range
but you look at that in your
and you're like
utah it was
or something like that but yeah it's
like oh let me let me shoot the missiles
into mexico and then we'll just go
this is all ridiculous it's like a
cartoon like you just stay is a [ __ ]
cartoon he is a [ __ ] cartoon people
are mad at me this morning because i was
posting his his uh his two central posts
and they're relevant they're relevant to
how scared he is why thursday matters
real well he's really saying this
anyone out there that is scared about um
parody or satire um named seth they are
actual real you can go verify them my
screenshots they are
from his account now i don't know maybe
we snuck in
and get them ourselves but who knows it
came from his account i mean what you
could do also is you could take the
screenshot
and then you could link it underneath
and just every time say for seth oh
force it love tony yeah see i don't want
to link out to true social [ __ ] that
[ __ ] most peop and that's why i post
them is because most people don't want
to go set up a [ __ ] account right so
i set up a count that way i can take the
relevant ones from his [ __ ] because
really all the other posts over there
aren't very relevant right right but his
post over there all of them are like i'm
endorsing this candidate right all the
more like
boilerplate kind of template of like
they all say the same thing this person
is great for this country and they're
gonna help white people that's what it
is that's what they say that's what his
thing says that's
nine times out of ten it's always about
this candidate is gonna do great to make
america great again for white people
right exactly well i mean
you know make america white again that's
what we want
speaking of competent we were talking
about competent government officials did
you see some of the clips from the
[ __ ] hearing that people to judge
absolutely dumps these [ __ ]
he is fantastic not only is pete buda
judge good at the politics part of all
this he's he's actually really serious
about policy and i said this morning
that i think he's going to be in
government for a very long time rather
he's part of an executive branch
right
absolutely first experienced person
right you know what i mean
about the policy and he's serious about
the politics watch this video
watch this is hilarious and it's it's a
long one here bear with me but it is
worth every single bit
of how
pete buddha judge just absolutely
[ __ ] unravels this scott perry this
trader scott perry yes let's watch
representative perry
thank you mr chairman secretary thanks
for being here
i'm sure you know
folks where i live my bosses my
constituents are paying about 80 percent
more for gasoline than they were
when president biden became the
president
again
their only personality trait
at this point is gas prices now i really
believe that they got in a room about a
month ago yeah or two months ago and
they're like we are going to run on gas
prices and that's what we're going to
win on they're going to run this gas on
amp like they run this tank
is what they're doing right
and they they're really trying to but
the problem is that the gas gets cheaper
and it keeps filling up the tank well
you know what's important about this and
and everyone should be talking about
this to everyone who will listen
any pro-democracy people out there that
want to politicize everything because i
talk about politicizing stuff we should
politicize the [ __ ] out of this gas
price thing that they're lying to you
and it's really easy for all americans
to understand that republicans have been
and are lying to them about gas prices
we they can see it in their [ __ ]
wallets in the price at the pump every
[ __ ] one of them know it
now these are the people you want in
charge right of our government who are
lying to you these are the same
[ __ ] scott perry is the same
[ __ ] who is sitting here
gaslighting you and gaslighting the
secretary of transportation about gas
prices as his number one personality
trait he's one of the [ __ ] main
members of congress who had everything
to do with the overturning of our
government
and the january 6th select committee is
is going to expose him in that way and
they're going to expose his lies a known
liar who is currently lying to you about
gas prices
something that is easily provable and
this is very important to politicize the
[ __ ] out of this politicize the [ __ ] out
of these people's lives but listen to
how he gaslights him not only about gas
prices but this is this is absolutely
fantastic gabe because i think this is
where republicans and conservatives and
the stupid [ __ ] online uh bitcoin bro
[ __ ] and elon simps
they all
they're
they're totally getting [ __ ] they're
totally getting [ __ ] here
joe rogan called trump a man baby the
trumped-up white audience that rogan has
he called them maybe this is totally
[ __ ] up their entire [ __ ] mojo
here because he's knocking on electric
vehicles how expensive they are not just
gas prices but how expensive electric
vehicles are so basically scott perry is
telling the secretary of transportation
there is no solution
right in reality that's what he's saying
listen and i think the response
i mean i think
i think it's fair to say that even you
have
implied that they should buy an electric
vehicle and absolve themselves of that
80 percent increase per gallon
just looking at kelly blue book the
price of a ev is about 55 000
i love how he goes to kelly blue book
which is what
dot com right
they they can't even go past they can't
even go past a consumer book
of what a consumer wants their car to be
worth right it's [ __ ] hilarious but
but listen to how he he gaslights here
and it sounds great in the moment from
this trader scott perry
now that doesn't include so
it's actually more than that because
there's 7 500
per car
uh subsidy paid for by about 48 billion
dollars in taxes on the same people
um
on that car so it's closer to about
which is completely [ __ ] untrue again
completely untrue that is not true it is
a subsidy but it's not the people the
subsidy does not come from the people
who pay for the electric car this is all
[ __ ] garbage let's listen sixty
thousand dollars there's about twenty
thousand dollars more than a
a gas driven uh passenger car about
forty thousand dollars more than the
average compact car
at the same time i'm sure you probably
also realize that
the average
pennsylvanian pays about 170 a month in
electricity
and that doesn't include the 10 to 15
percent that it that has just gone up so
that's an old number so it's actually
more than that
and based on mr massey's numbers which
so he's talking about thomas massey here
now listen when scott perry scott
perry's trying to make sure pete buddha
judge understands when you buy an
electric car game then you actually have
to charge it with electric as opposed to
putting gas in it
yeah he explains it really well here
like as if no one knew that yeah i
thought you buy an electric car and it
just always has electric you don't have
to like people aren't used to charging
things or something right you tell me an
electric vehicle requires electricity
you got to charge the son of a [ __ ]
yeah it's got batteries in it you gotta
charge one then dude forget that listen
i don't know i don't doubt at all
if they could afford the electric
vehicle
and plug it in we're talking about
another
90 100 a month in electric costs oh my
god whoa whoa whoa whoa
a hundred dollars in electric costs how
many gallons of gas at his delusional
price that he thinks that he would love
the gaslight people that gas is actually
the price of he he would love to tell
people gas is eight dollars a gallon and
he would probably do it with a straight
[ __ ] face that for a month right and
then 10 gallons that's not saying like
oh i go to a charging station which
could cost me less right especially on
non-peak hours right you have that where
he's going to say 90 to 100 which in the
grand scheme you average that out you've
got three dollars a day right that's
probably you know that's half of what
you spend on a coffee
a day right three dollars a day on
average you're using these using using
these numbers using using the traders
his dumb math
if you look at that it's three dollars a
day 90 90 bucks to 100 bucks a month
right but if if if you're filling up
your tank
one and a half to two three times a
month
like my tank is i think 14 gallons 16
gallons i'm like that and i probably
paid
i don't know uh 50 60 bucks to fill it
up you know maybe like oh depending what
the price is
but that's on one that's on one fill up
right
so what happens when i try to fill up
twice no no no no no no no
i'm gonna stop i'm gonna stop you there
i'm gonna stop you there gabe because
what you're doing is you're using logic
you're using math and that hurts their
that hurts their argument here
scott perry really actually said hey the
cost of electric is gonna be less than
the cost of gas he's saying it out loud
right right and he's like oh electric
cars are really expensive which right
they're not right they're not but the
thing is they can't do the math of like
what's the short-term cost and the
long-term cost and if we were to assess
those right
you would say oh i'm spending less money
probably not too long after purchasing
said electric car
right you're gonna be spending less
money than you would on using a gasoline
car right now i am in agreeance here
that electric cars don't really reduce
carbon footprint because i think that
that argument's kind of debunked a lot
of people want to make the argument that
it reduces a carbic footprint the reason
why it doesn't is because we still do
not we're not in a position in this
country to say that a lot of our
electric is is is created in a green way
that reduces the carbon footprint which
is something we're trying to work
towards but that's the infrastructure we
have to build over time we can't just
especially when you have a cheeto dust
confederacy where these states don't
want to participate in this
infrastructure bill
um
build
to make sure that green energy is part
of it and force the electric companies
to move away from coal and some other
non-green types of electric production
so
but what pete buda judge and the
department of transportation are saying
is look
if you want to reduce the gasoline
bill not only will it reduce your
personal bill but it will also reduce
the demand for gasoline and that's the
other factor that scott perry doesn't
even consider here that if if there was
a significant percentage of americans
who chose to use electric as opposed to
gasoline it would reduce the demand for
gasoline and we all know from economic
crazy that's crazy
i know
that demand would actually supply the
the increase in uh supply
will lower the price and also
the decrease in demand will lower the
price so you're telling me that if i
were to shift down my demand
right not only would the americans who
have the electric cars be paying less
for their fuel
the electric for their cars but also the
americans who still have gasoline-driven
cars would be playing lester their fuel
this is really [ __ ] this is simple
economics it's simple [ __ ] to understand
it really isn't that difficult i think
it's super simple but i can i can
probably point out a couple bros on
twitter that is like yeah i took finance
and let me tell you i got a c in
economics
and then they would they would say like
oh yeah dude i'm a [ __ ] pro you
clearly do like when when i went
you need to invest in nfts in bitcoin
and that will solve your gasoline
problem like when i went after elon and
like basically went through the
financials to be like this is how much
he has this is how much he still has not
guaranteed this is what the cost would
be this this is people like oh comedian
doing math
oh bro i know more finance than you do
and i'm like all right bet
and they're they're probably funnier
than you too it's probably the thing
that's probably here's the thing i think
i'm the funniest person in the world but
i know i'm funnier than these [ __ ]
oh your math is funny that's all that
matters you libtard let's listen let's
listen to traitor here do his stupid
[ __ ] math
i'm wondering what the administration
and you are doing other than subsidizing
other than subsidized
to um to lower the he really [ __ ]
hates that he really hates that
because that reduces the cost
it reduces the cost i hate reducing cost
for my constituents right i i want to
help my constituents but i don't want to
help them he said at the beginning he's
like you know my my boss my constituents
like if that really was the case and you
did have a boss and you were trying to
be like hey so as an employee
what am i going to do to make the
company and myself look great okay i'm
either going to uh make it i'm going to
reduce the cost for you the company the
shareholders oh i'm going to say ah [ __ ]
it you know what's actually better for
you if you spend more money
than you should
that'll make you happier right
it's hilarious let's let's let's get to
the because i want to watch
um
pete putin just slam him here so let's
go to that lost look they're either
paying more for gas 80 percent
or they're paying more for
electricity to the tune of essentially
doubling their electricity bill like
how's this getting better
for my bosses
there he is again with the my boss
what do you plan to do about that cost
other than subsidies
well i'm very glad you asked that
question
um he's like i knew you [ __ ] would ask
this
certainly not me
thinks that all or even most americans
can easily afford electric vehicles that
said i'm i'm i'm struck by this 55 000
number that
keeps going around he's like i don't
know where you got this and who's making
this up i knew this might come up so i
just pulled a few of the latest prices
he's like uh i brought receipts [ __ ]
right
like i brought i knew you were gonna say
this
so i looked it up on kelly blue book
right and this is what i found well he
actually he actually goes to the source
of the actual manufacturer in the car
here now they have a little back and
forth about the subsidy and stuff and
the secretary here isn't exactly clear
where that cost comes in but listen to
the actual cost of these vehicles the
starting price of these vehicles
versus what scott perry said and then
i'll tell you why
why the secretary is saying one price
and scott perry is saying the other a
chevy bolt so an american-made 2022
uh ev is
five hundred 26
five dollars uh if you want a pickup
truck uh like a chevy silverado ev
america pew pew you wanna pick up truck
here we go here we go let's see what the
what what the okay yeah these people are
[ __ ] blind let's see let's see what
the electric trump truck will cost or
ford uh f-150 lightning uh the starting
prices of those are thirty nine thousand
nine hundred and thirty nine thousand
nine hundred seventy-four that sounds a
lot less than sixty thousand which scott
perry sounds like a lot less yeah a lot
like significantly less right right
let's listen respectively
pre-subsidy or post-subsidy uh you know
i think it depends on which uh
he's like i'm gonna [ __ ] get you on
this right i got you here i got you here
mayor pete
or post look it's not even if it was it
wouldn't be a big difference but also it
doesn't really matter right now well it
does matter because what what perry was
saying is that the the 55 000 is post
that is post that's what he's saying his
post right right well right that's he
stuck his his [ __ ] flag in the sand
saying that price was supposed
to judge like well i don't know but what
does it matter if even if this is post
i'm still thirty thousand dollars
cheaper than what you said you dumb
[ __ ] like what does it matter
like literally literally pete buddha
just is giving giving scott perry a
vehicle that he says costs 55 000
he's bringing proof that no it is half
that cost doesn't matter it doesn't
matter about the subsidies
i would love to be like scott perry show
me where you got this and let's do just
some simple whiteboard math then during
the week katie
state subsidies as well i don't think so
no okay so uh
and look that that's uh you know the new
car so the first time i got a plug-in
car for example chaston and i got one it
was uh fourteen thousand dollars uh had
about fifteen thousand miles on as a
c-max uh so it's a combo uh plug-in
hybrid
oh you you you and your personal
experience you son of a [ __ ]
you're able to give some sort of
personal anecdote here right and how
dare you how dare you bring up your gay
marriage in front of me because that
offends me right right because i voted
against it scott perry he's gonna be
like wait wait you know i could i could
easily see scott perry coming back like
whoa plug-in it's hybrid well that's not
what we're talking about here we're not
talking about these hybrid things what's
next huh you're gonna you know it's like
well what happens here at the end and
i'm not gonna play because i want to go
to the what was that because we need
time to make for that but i want to
explain the audience what the difference
is between the kelly blue blook
kelly blue book price that scott perry's
talking about and pete buddha judge so
the kelly blue book price and i'm sure
if you go online you look it up it's an
average between the vehicles and when
kelly blue book doesn't average between
the vehicles they don't take the the
bottom dollar
um
off the line bare bare bones models they
take the actual high-end models of those
vehicles and and that's probably where
they get the average yeah so
if we had the right like if you had the
the bigger rims and you had the right
four-wheel drive
right the heavy-duty edition the the
leather seats that whatever the [ __ ] the
options are right
right the 15-20 grand that's gonna get
you over the top exactly right that's
where kelly buick what pete buddha judge
is saying is hey these are available on
the market yes there's more expensive
electric cars out there we all know that
not everyone can afford them right
exactly and that's what the subsidies
are for is to make sure that people who
are just out of the range of affording
an electric car which would save them
huge amounts of money
that that subsidy puts them in the range
to buy that electric car so they can
save huge amounts of money and and
here's here's the actual investment
right that we have for our country not
just in our infrastructure but the
people when you talk about that seventy
five hundred dollar subsidy because
really in today's world seventy five
hundred dollars for a vehicle doesn't
seem like a lot of money
but it is when you consider that someone
who could not afford the extra 7 500 now
can save substantial substantially
amount more during the month
on their monthly budget because most
people
get paid on a weekly a bi-weekly or
monthly basis that's how they trade
their labor i've said it before you're
trading your labor to your employer
that's how they receive their paychecks
that's how they normally budget their
expenses and so that and everyone knows
this month i live month to month you've
heard this before and that is what the
administration is trying to get at it is
to help people with their month-to-month
budget so they're not living month to
month
they can have disposable income which
gave by the way when people have
disposable income they spend it that's
what happens they don't save a lot they
spend it which which actually helps
demand on the economy and helps drive
the economy so these republicans they
want high gas prices they want high
prices on electric vehicles so people
can't afford them so that way you can't
save money on your fuel and you can't
you can't start building towards the new
infrastructure of automobiles in this
country they they definitely want you to
have to live
month to month so they can blame it on
socialism and democrats this is what
they want they want to they want a
fascist state they don't want
pro-democracy and that's why scott perry
pulled these stupid [ __ ] numbers out
of his ass he knows what he's doing here
this isn't he's dumb he knows what he's
doing and and the gas price thing i
think it is beautiful that they decided
to make this their number one
personality trait i think it's beautiful
and i think it's gonna backfire on it on
them really bad because the american
people see exactly what kind of [ __ ]
these [ __ ] idiots are trying to sell
them so i'm gonna go to the uh the what
was that here um what is this what is
this edition about
so this edition
is about the internet troll uh alex
stein
uh and he was the one oh this yeah this
is the guy because aoc was arrested
yesterday but she was arrested for
protesting he should have been arrested
for sexual harassment it seems right
right but here's the thing not that too
much of a spoiler but he does have a
history of this type of behavior
so we're going to learn a lot about alex
stein in this edition look there's a ton
of other stuff his family has his own
shady history
i was not able to dive into that no um
just because of time but also it's like
i would rather keep it focused on him
i'm sure a simple search on kelly blue
book would give you uh yeah i know it'll
give you that they would give yeah they
would give you the history it would
totally give you the history yeah i'm
sure i'm sure just like scott perry
that's his go-to it's kelly's blue book
yeah i'm sure i'm sure that would so
let's go to what was that
here on the tony michaels podcast
gabe sanchez let me let me get this
right because you've got it on yeah
there we go yeah let's let's do this
you only pull this down there we go
let's just play it bare here let's do it
turn it up q and on conspiracy troll and
used car salesman alex stein sexually
harassed representative aoc on the steps
of the capitol he filmed the harassment
and posted it to his social media
accounts but now he's complaining that
he's being cancelled by the lame stream
media
[Music]
just some quick background in alex stein
or as he refers to himself as primetime
99 alex stein he comes from a wealthy
part of dallas texas called highland
park where most of stein's high school
classmates found him annoying immature
and you guessed it desperate for
attention anyway i'm sure most of you by
now have seen the video of stein
sexually harassing aoc on the capitol
steps but if you haven't here it is aoc
my favorite big booty latina i love you
aoc you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on aoc that's my favorite big
booty latina
i love it my favorite aoc nice to meet
you look how sexy she looks in that
dress
oh i love it aoc
hot like a tamale well i guess if anyone
out there is casting for the role of
cat-calling construction worker you know
who to call but seriously though as
someone from the hispanic community i
find this behavior incredibly offensive
it's not only racist but also sexist
whatever your political affiliation or
personal opinion of aoc is i hope we can
agree that someone calling a woman their
favorite big booty latina is both
insulting and disrespectful especially
when they're accusing said woman of
wanting to kill babies and to the white
dudes out there saying it's just a joke
don't be so sensitive well then i'm sure
you wouldn't mind women joking about
your weed
weenies right here's the thing comedians
like stein are not funny their go-to
comedy routine is to punch down and
target marginal groups for a cheap laugh
the legendary comedian george carlin
said it best i think his core audience
are young white males who are threatened
by these groups i think a lot of these
guys aren't sure their manhood because
that's a problem when you're going in
through adolescence
you know am i really i mean could i be i
hope i'm not one of them and the women
who assert themselves and are competent
are a threat to these men and so are
immigrants in terms of jobs after the
harassment on the capital steps stein
started going on a right-wing media tour
to defend his lewd behavior and one of
the stops was margie taylor green's
podcast which makes total sense since
green is obsessed with aoc so aoc who
who was very upset you know you're a
comedian you're doing what you do
saying things are actually quite the
compliments i was complimenting she's
jenny from the block i mean ajlo is
known for her voluptuous derriere and
all i was trying to do is say you look
great i don't know why and i'm in texas
and you're in georgia so we have
southern hospitality that's how we talk
you're a beautiful lady you are a very
beautiful lady and that and i don't mean
that anything sexual i'm just saying i'm
just commenting on your beauty i don't
think that that for me is some sort of
negative thing but they live in a
society where compliments are bigotry
and based in racism
it is it's it's terrible but but in our
how we feel in our culture where we
believe in um you know two genders yeah
no no there's 17 actually now
that's what some people say i know it's
insane but no it's i think women should
be confident if someone if a man gives
you a compliment
a woman can say thank you that's a good
thing say thank you or you know if she's
going up the stairs and someone's
yelling stuff at her she can just wave
and go on
and not go into full outrage wait what
was that say thank you or you know if
she's going up the stairs and someone's
yelling stuff at her she can just wave
and go on
and not go into full outrage so aoc
feels uncomfortable and unsafe and
marjorie taylor green a fellow
congresswoman responds by saying that
aoc should take stein's gross behavior
as a compliment and say thank you these
two have officially set up camp in that
she was asking for it territory and i
just want to point out that i watched
the whole episode and the amount of
stupidity that they packed into 60
minutes was astounding and right on cue
stein is claiming that he's being
cancelled by aoc in the lame stream
media after his dc comedy show was
called off this whole white guy whining
about being cancelled thing is getting
pretty old so let's clear something up
there is no such thing as cancel culture
it's called being held accountable for
your actions you've got free speech
which means you can say and do whatever
you want but others can choose to deal
with you however they want oh and by the
way stein relocated his dc comedy show
to the steps of the capitol and this was
the turnout so yeah i'm sure the venue
is really regretting not hosting his set
especially when it consists of spreading
disinformation about michael jordan the
basketball player owning private prisons
look it up one of the biggest guys that
owns private prisons michael jordan has
one of the biggest investors in private
prison so that's no joke and if it
wasn't clear michael jordan a basketball
player does not own any stake in private
prisons this guy does also i don't know
if that was supposed to be some sort of
weird unofficial ted talk or an
anti-humor bit but according to stein
this was him keeping it real in the hood
the main reason that stein has become
well known is thanks to texas house bill
2840 which requires governmental bodies
to give time to public speakers and as a
result stein has exploited this rule to
spread misinformation conspiracy
theories and transphobia and because of
those stunts his videos have gone viral
and he has been welcomed on right-wing
shows like alex jones and tucker carlson
which helped build his platform as a
troll in june stein took his trolling to
a gop convention in texas where he went
after dan crenshaw calling him eye patch
mccain and then at that same event went
after ted cruz i know but why do you do
that you go become best friends with
trump after he makes fun of you and your
wife why do you do that i i understand
you don't want it
well if there's one thing i got from
this encounter it's that no one likes
ted cruz not even the people that have
been radicalized within the republican
party now what you might not know is
that alex stein was also a former
contestant on different reality tv shows
though not that anyone would even notice
since each of his appearances were very
short-lived in 2012 stein was a
contestant on the reality tv show the
glass house
and boy was it something at the end of
the day i'm a good guy with good morals
would you look at that a bad guy
thinking that they are the good guy
sounds like a republican to me and it
should come as no surprise that stein
also sexually harassed a female
contestant while he was on the show
right behind you andrea your husband
would be so this is probably the most
naked man you've seen in a long time
wildly inappropriate kevin is a little
baby back [ __ ] i mean it's 2012. people
need to loosen up a little bit his
excuse is that it's 2012.
later on in the first episode stein
asked the audience if he should become a
villain should i turn into the most epic
villain in the history of reality tv
it's fantastic
however stein was so bad at playing a
villain that he served no purpose he
just annoyed everyone and by the end of
the first episode almost every
contestant voted him off the show now at
this point stein and another contestant
have been sent to the elimination round
however that other contestant decided to
quit so now it's just stein let's see
how the audience voted
[Music]
imagine being overwhelmingly voted off
by the other contestants your opponent
in the elimination round quits and the
audience still doesn't want you to be on
the show and don't forget this is the
very same audience who told stein that
he should become a villain but here's
the thing there's a big difference
between playing a villain on a tv show
and being an [ __ ] no one wants to
watch an [ __ ] i'm sure if alexstein
was asked he would defend all of his
past and present behavior as him just
playing a character but if you watch him
over the years you realize that his
primetime 99 alex stein character is
really just alex stein a sexist and
racist [ __ ] well i'm gabe sanchez and
this has been what was that
[Music]
what was that what was that what was
that by gabe sanchez fantastic fantastic
episode [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy
because i hate people who use the excuse
of it's comedy it's funny you just don't
understand the humor when you're
attacking a marginalized group a woman a
person of color whatever it might be
that's not funny you are punching down
you're not punching up as a as a
critique or or a way to comment on on
societal issues
right you're taking your your um
your your energy out on someone else who
can't necessarily defend for themselves
so when stein goes around and like tries
to defend his behavior and say oh it's
just a joke and it was commentary
it's like no it wasn't it was you
being a sexist and racist [ __ ] that's
what it is
he he is and and i i did not know about
the uh the part where he sexually
harassed someone on the oh yeah dude no
one has talked about this so i mean no
idea it is out there
but you'd have to know to look for it so
you don't have to go anywhere
right you do not have to go anywhere now
you just go to what was that with gabe
sanchez so check it out check it out um
we'll probably have that up on the midas
touch youtube channel the minus touch
network youtube channel soon that's
where those go premiere other than here
on the tony michaels podcast so we'll
put it on the playlist as soon as it's
over there and the hope is if i can get
it done today there will be another one
whoa tomorrow tomorrow that'll be a
recap of day seven so fingers crossed i
can get this done right right well so so
check out the playlist that we have on
our youtube channel that is why you must
subscribe to our youtube channel here at
the name
the tony michaels podcast that wrong one
wrong one what was that what was that
finger it's going all over i know all
over the place man
um
we're gonna we're gonna uh so go to the
minus touch channel and subscribe
because gabe we have we have a hearing
tomorrow um which is gonna be a big news
big yes
i'm i don't know if i'm going to make a
i have a beer or if i'm going to make
like a like a cocktail or something it
is it is the evening it is it is it's
the evening i'll have them i know i will
definitely have my bowl of popcorn next
to me okay and i'm still figuring out
what my beverage of choice will be for
tomorrow night oh okay well you know you
know maybe in the uh
in tribute to trump maybe i'll get a
bowl of beanie weenies you know there
you go i don't know maybe maybe
you know just just just contribute of
him
what do you think is going to happen
tomorrow i mean really there's a lot of
speculation i know they're going to run
through the tic tac of
of that time during the capital but from
the perspective of where trump was what
he was doing what he wasn't doing what
do you suspect is going to be the b
because adam kinsinger on sunday already
you know kind of floated that hey
there's going to be big stuff that no
one's seen before do you think it's
stuff we already know we're just going
to see the evidence of or do you think
it's going to be like holy [ __ ] like
some of the secret service stuff and the
ketchup stuff yeah yeah yeah i think i
think what's gonna happen is there's a
there's a a pattern or or an existing
kind of precedent that they've
established here right they're going to
use what is existing because remember
they're they in this season of this
series that is the january 6th hearings
they are world building so they're
building on previous things that they
have said or they've mentioned right and
what they're going to do i think in this
one is going to more or less go over
right the tick tock as you've said of
what happened some of these things we
know like he just sat around watching
fox news he waited to go outside and
give his i love you speech to people and
he had different drafts of that right
exactly
we've had hints of that along the way
and i think what's going to happen is
we're going to we're going to hear those
things
but coupled with those i think are going
to be like details we're like whoa i'm
sorry what was that like those are the
moments that we're going to have we're
going to say you have to make two or
three episodes just on this hearing i
know i know
but i think that's what's gonna happen
is you're gonna hear
what we've heard before or at least
we've heard whispers right somebody said
something but it wasn't really
corroborated or it was just kind of
hearsay and i think especially with a
couple people who quit on january 6
those people are going to come forward
and be like i was there and this [ __ ]
was [ __ ] nuts because that's the
witnesses that right there like we tried
to stop them ivanka came in jared came
in don jr tried to text him meadows was
kind of passively whatever is going to
happen cassidy hutchinson was like we
got to say something you know uh eric
hershman was like we got to do something
you know there's i think there's going
to be a lot of details and uh i think
it's going to be
pretty revealing but if you go based on
the other ones that's precedent the last
seven you'll see that they have
built on what we've already heard or had
suspicions about but have added these
like whoa
can we roll can we just can we come back
put ketchup put ketchup on the details
in other words right yeah yeah exactly
you know make them easier to eat
sometimes yeah yeah and paper is like
easier to eat when it has ketchup on it
right for sure exactly exactly but you
know i actually believe because of the
two witnesses we're gonna see
um the deputy press secretary testify
and she
quit almost immediately yeah um as the
cat after the capital siege um where
they tried to steal our democracy away
from us and kill mike pence um you also
are going to hear a live testimony from
a national security adviser on the
national security council
who who resigned right straight away
after that but i think what is very
significant about that not just their
resignations
but why they actually resigned so
i believe they're going to tell what
they saw
what they heard
and what they believed was happening in
real time which led them to that
resignation
some of the
disgusting vile [ __ ] that i think
that is going to be revealed tomorrow
is that donald trump the sitting
president united states at the time
was not only sitting there knowing
that
and he knew it in real time that they
were there to kill mike pence
they were there to kill other
politicians and they were there to
overthrow the actual election and the
counting to make sure that donald trump
was to remain in power to commit a coup
he knew that in real time and i think
not only did he know that he was excited
about it right yeah and i think that's
probably i i don't know for sure but i
get this sense that with the deputy
press secretary and what we've seen
the text message from kaylee mcindy who
would be her boss who would be the press
secretary and like uh sean hannity and
things
it just feels like to me
that the national security council
advisor and this deputy press secretary
are probably going to say yeah the
reason why we left is because he was
excited about overturning our
constitution
it wasn't just he did it yeah i mean
the other thing too is you look at the
video right he's like i love you he made
that video but this is also in response
to people willing to die
for
him right they're willing to break the
law they're willing to go to jail
they're willing to to to uh deal in or
get the consequences you know of their
actions right um
that's what they want that's or that's
what he wants rather is he wants them to
put their lives on the line because that
is how he knows
that
they love him right he takes it as
validation he takes it as i feel
important because they're willing to
break in and and take over and in hog
tie and and hang mike pence like all of
these things
that he was very like oh yeah that
sounds great yeah go do [ __ ] do that
go go hang him go
go hog tie this person go take over go
get the fake electors like all of these
things these are people that were
willing to to break the law for him and
as he saw them on fox news on live
television drinking his diet coke he was
like
i love these people because they love me
and crazy enough it is true
and that's what this this uh post is
about on his fraudulent social media
account tooth central as he calls it at
his rallies now this seems irrelevant on
its face because it's about the stephen
colbert staff that were arrested and
kicked out of the capitol and charged
with trespassing you guys remember this
during a select hearing
but this is way more this is way deeper
of his fear of what's going to happen on
thursday because he wants the country to
rally around his supporters who
committed federal felonies and tried to
kill the vice president united states
they tried to kill other members of
congress
and they to try to overthrow the
government of the united states and he's
trying to he's trying to conflate it
with this story about the stephen
colbert being released of charges
because it's not about the people who
are being charged and in prison who
tried to
make him dictator and king because if it
really was he would have pardoned them
he didn't he didn't give a [ __ ] about
them he only cares about himself here
but listen listen to what this statement
says and i think this is why it's so
important and it goes to his mindset
here why this is actually relevant in
our actual news cycle he says wow
prosecutors have just dropped all the
charges against ratings challenge
colbert show staffers which is
you know he's always got to make the dig
that colbert right i mean if they are
ratings challenge why do you give a [ __ ]
but he says who entered because he wants
to be on tv the only time he's able to
be on tv
is when he does a phone interview with
uh sean hannity they never show his face
doesn't do it live right he just did a
line of [ __ ] adderall and he's like
calling sean handy
or the next time he's on camera is when
he's at a rally and he can only hold so
many you know i mean geez his wife his
ex-wife died and he was already ready to
go on the next round yeah well i mean
you know he had to get rid of her and
you know get someone to toss her down
the stairs so now you can't have his
route this is ridiculous but what he
says here is who entered the capital
illegally now i'm going to break down
some of the statement here disregarded
police warning
wouldn't lead the premises and were very
loud and disruptive
late into the evening with no security
at present as a mandated by law
these radical left lunatics from a
failing show were treated so differently
than the unselects are treating so many
of our great american patriots not fair
he literally he literally says at the
very end not fair like what a [ __ ]
baby the whining
oh my god
he can't take it here's the thing like
they were there filming
a comedy sketch okay they were there
they were actually
for alex steins that is actual comedy
alex right right they had
they had the insult dog there right
there's a whole bit right they had a
guide
and then they're like oh you guys
shouldn't be here in this you know
during this time or whatever they
weren't causing they weren't loud and
disruptive what's funny about this is he
claims they entered the capitol the
actual hearing room for the select
committee is not in the it's in an
adjacent building it's not in the actual
it's not on the house floor i think that
he would know that no he does the fact
that he was planning the coup and
telling people where to go yeah well he
didn't know he didn't know where to go
that's why he had to have members of
congress like scott perry and others
tell them where to go to right that's
why he tried to get secret service to
drive him right he's like i can't walk
there i don't know where i'm going right
what do you think what do you think i
know how to use a map you think i can
ride a bike you think i can ride a bike
up to the capitol what is it what do you
think of joe biden who can actually ride
a [ __ ] bike this is ridiculous he's
like you think i can you think i can
place where i am on the map right now
[ __ ] i just drew an extra dick on on
florida right here with a hurricane
but this is really crazy crazy [ __ ] and
this goes to his mindset here he is
absolutely terrified of thursday folks
he is terrified terrified not because he
thinks he's going to get away with these
crimes but what he's really scared of is
that the entire country is going to know
exactly what he was trying to do and
that is what terrifies him
terrified him he won on an hour and a
half 13 tweet or
truth
uh yeah we featured we featured several
of them right there why in live in real
time i could not keep up after the
hearings i got like six to eight and i
was like nope this is uh it's not you
can go watch that you can go watch in
real time you can go back to the
mindsets youtube channel we had michael
cohen giving five
day five or day six days
day six yeah yeah it was the emergency
hearing yesterday day six michael cohen
giving some perspective on on trump's
kind of mindset in that moment you know
uh and i was i was flashing up as many
[ __ ]
posters
as many as you could pull i was flashing
them and and it was it was deranged and
he's he's a scared scared little baby
and he's he's a scared animal in a
corner
and this is what's going to happen
tomorrow so don't forget to go set your
reminder because it's going to be hugely
important that you know what the january
6th select committee how they're going
to do the tic tac here i think adam
kinzinger is supposed to be the one
who's going to do most of the hearing
and preside over the script now to go
through exactly what happened and to
play those videos and to actually
question the witnesses we know benny
thompson actually
he's been tested positive for coven so i
think liz cheney
will actually chair the committee which
is even better even better than a
republic gabe this situation where benny
thompson you know i hope he gets better
but the actual fact that a republican is
going to chair the committee
she is going to chair the committee i
think and i i don't know if she will or
not or if adam schiff steps in but i
believe i believe they will hand her the
gavel like oh you want to destroy trump
here you go here's the gap knock it
[ __ ] down so don't forget to set your
reminder go to midastouch network's
youtube channel right after the show
right here go after the show and set
your reminder that that thumbnail that
day eight is at the very top that link
is there don't forget because we will
start our coverage at 7 00 p.m eastern
tomorrow on thursday an hour before the
hearing with our great midas touch
network panel now we'll probably have
texas paul nba
trump nba killer jessica denson why the
legal afres will have uh karen agnipolo
kfa and popoc we'll have the mizellas
brothers from the minus touch podcast
i'm sure david bender will be joining us
and we'll have several other
personalities michael cohen from
milecopa that will probably join us so
please go set that reminder to make sure
you do not miss out even if you can't
watch it live still set that reminder
because it'll put it in your queue to
re-watch that thing it is going to be
super important for our democracy for
you to politicize every single point of
how this [ __ ] scumbag tried to not
only steal our democracy but was willing
to stand aside and let his vice
president be killed be hung
just so he can maintain power yeah oh
the other thing i wouldn't be surprised
if they write it into the script about
the text messages
probably
honestly if you're going to have prime
time coverage and you want to call out
the [ __ ] that was they requested
those text messages and then they were
deleted
and then you were only able to recover
one of them these text messages were
professionally
they were removed right because and
let's go through that tomorrow on the
show because that's the other thing is
we'll broadcast at our regular time
tomorrow noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcast from the minus touch facebook
page and then we'll do the hearing on
the midas touch network tomorrow evening
so let's do that tomorrow gabe let's
make sure we break down like these text
messages and how in the [ __ ] hell
can secrets because if gabe if they
wanted our text messages i bet there's
one i bet there's one agency in the
world that could find our text messages
yeah and that's probably the secret
[ __ ] service until tomorrow until
tomorrow at noon eastern right here on
the tony michaels podcast again go set
your reminder for the hearing surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules no boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking